[Music]
how's the girlfriend
my name's Beth today we're playing a Sun
key the game
I am DB rated this game the best Sonic
game since Sonic 4 life supply oh my god
did you see that
oh god cop right start no no no no no no
no don't show me stop this Biersack
tails I'll thank God
whoa two more seconds in this video
would have been claimed what the [ __ ]
was that yeah look at him go
[Music]
yeah no no my I shake my aspirin I'm
some narrow juice maybe you would live
crow [ __ ] let me tickle your face say
with me breasts oh my god how do you
sing that high I am dead the case you
haven't gotten yet this isn't parody of
all the sonic duck XE games Oh No Sonic
what happened to him I keep shaking my
buttcheeks na anytime I see sanic sanic
sanic man is truly a to go fast
it's truly is the greatest Sonic game
[Applause]
tell-tell she's gonna get your chance
no don't cry don't cry
I'll give okay okay oh yeah this is
happening this is probably scarier than
the sonic.exe okay okay so that we
finished tails we got two more next one
is goddamn copyright god damn it stop it
all right right neckl we're playing as
Nichols my favorite sanic you might not
be able to run but I may need to double
okay [ __ ] is this song
Roger tits
all right dirt it's Roger tits I like uh
started to set blood oh god no
okay what is happening hammering oh god
it's a ghost in such sonic court that
became all outdated me me know what
happened okay that red sanic sanic what
are you doing that except this jump I'm
glad I can jump in this game I was
worried that I couldn't
[ __ ] sake sonic you're not space babe
sandy can keep telling you as soon as
they told him oh okay I'm gonna lick the
air now I cry tears over how beautiful
this game is so many dances to dance so
little dance would you dance I ask
myself every day police put that on my
gravestone I can't even be bothered I
got all my sisters with me we got
missing mr. Eggman or mr. Robotnik he
has all these different names [ __ ] yeah
yeah so in the original sonic.exe he you
can moonwalk with him it's [ __ ]
amazing
but I guess you can't really do that in
this one so I was gonna rate it
11 out of 12 but now it will only get a
12 out of 12 all right Robotnik is blind
he's going to the dark for some reason
fabulous absolutely fabulous and he's
falling that could also be a crab that's
handicapped
[Music]
fashion
do the dance moves
[Music]
that is it yeah speaking
fashion they're the dance looks like I'm
jerking two dicks sorry that no
jump-scare seni ha i occasionally suck
is that the plural of sonic 1 sonic many
songs okay
you fiddled that up
yes turn out it had
skunky their game in with latest level
okay we have three levels actually maybe
even four level fun level the green one
level moist I rat it it's not done yet
okay damn it how do I get I'll go with
level fun please yes this is indeed
level fun
can't you tell how far I am
ah I convenient god I love play Sonic
games it's almost like they play them
they play themselves [ __ ] yes
keep going Sonic I don't know about your
friends but it looks like sonic has a
little bit of a beer belly up still got
it
never mind go sonic you're my hero
I love you I would make babies video
unless it was a vehicle oh of costs
Sonic games are my thing
okay go go go go go go go go go yeah
there you go take that mr. egg it's
Robotnik's donkey did it thanks I love
doing things how did they know okay
level the green one can't wait for the
moist one shut up Nate a77
[Music]
NASA except no [ __ ]
[ __ ] is this sorry boom
[Music]
ah
so yes I tell them how to cry I'm gonna
cry
oh okay this is really moist
[Music]
now gross those you don't know this is
nearly how the inside of a vagina looks
like that's me I would know never mind
Oh God aah I can't dive but now they
smell lovely this yeah thank you come
here there we go what the [ __ ] is that
supposed to be wait where do I know this
song
don't say it man you ain't kazooie yeah
it's [ __ ] awesome game awesome
soundtrack are you [ __ ] kidding me
wow that go this way then great I'm
going this way this is this is the high
location oops I meant the other way
aren't I
a silly little biscuit a silly biscuit
unique well then I guess we [ __ ] go
this way then jesus [ __ ] christ what
do you want from me sonic no no
for [ __ ] sake why do I swim like a
ghost all right FAT FAT FAT FAT better
butter butter but but since you were
angry from all the walk you don't know
that I mean yeah I'm not angry
I made you at from all the boys I get it
no that that's [ __ ] hilarious
how do you like that yeah I guess
getting a little bit tired of this
[ __ ] level not gonna lie but we're
cheap doing it cuz videogames and
science mainly science but this possibly
it could it be I don't believe it
is this the end of the tunnel please be
the end of the tunnel for [ __ ] sake
this maze is not so amazing is it yes
that was a joke feel free to laugh [ __ ]
oh my
[Music]
yes oh my god I actually did it what
does it say you win a life
okay then [ __ ] you and all your children
oh okay here it is okay okay
so get in a day ah this game just makes
me want to touch
that was it huh okay yeah great well I
had fun did you have fun we all had fun
[Music]
hi I'm Deb and thank you for watching
leave a like if you enjoyed don't don't
do anything you will regret and I will
see you in the next one here's the
picture of a man kid saying holding a
bread and doing thumbs up I hope that
will make you thumbs up this video now
I'll see you bye